like many of you we are following
guidelines to stay home as much as
possible and we ask you please please
please do the same we begin with this
the president he's laid out the
administration's plan to begin reopening
this country suggesting less affected
states could start doing so by today so
it includes three phases to gradually
lessen restrictions in order for state
to reopen it would have to meet and
maintain certain criteria what does that
include lessening of the symptoms in
cases within a 14-day period hospitals
would have to be able to treat all
patients without being overwhelmed and
they have to test health care workers
after initially claiming total authority
the president now says this decision is
in the hands of the governor's I don't
want anyone coming back that isn't in
position to come back the last thing we
want is for let's say a New York to come
back to soon I think it'll be much
faster than people think I think it'll
be quicker but it's got to be safe
meanwhile this is the first active duty
service member to die from the
coronavirus 41 year old Charles Thacker
jr. of Arkansas was a sailor on board
the USS Theodore Roosevelt he was
diagnosed March 30th and died two weeks
later 655 sailors on board the aircraft
carrier have tested positive still an
ongoing crisis there every Friday we are
taking time to answer your most pressing
questions about the corona virus as
president Trump looks to reopen the
country many of you have questions about
what our new normal
might look like so we brought in our
senior medical correspondent that's dr.
Tara Narula she's here with some answers
dr. Andrew lo good morning so the
president's guidelines are non-binding
and he left it up to governor's so
there's gonna be some variability here
but generally speaking what might the
new normal look like when we begin this
phased reopening well it's definitely
going to be new Tony and it's going to
mean distancing but a little bit of
freedom so the first important thing
that they recommend it is that
vulnerable populations continue to
shelter in place for the rest of us who
may venture out it's important to
maintain that
maximal distance between others and
avoid social gatherings of more than 10
people when you look at other social
gathering type events whether it's at a
movie theater or at a restaurant those
types of events are going to be allowed
as long as you're able to maintain
maximum social distance that's the same
for gyms interestingly bars are not
going to be allowed to open in this
phase one schools that have been closed
should remain closed when we're talking
about the workforce workers can begin to
slowly go back in phases so maybe 20% of
the workforce and 40% then 80 percent
and also in there encouraging telework
for that phase one process as well
limited to no visits to nursing
facilities and hospitals so those are
really going to continue to be
prohibited and then minimizing
non-essential travel so we aren't really
sure because of under testing how many
Americans have this illness we also out
of South Korea there are reports that
people who have had it may be able to
get it a second time so with those two
facts in mind how worried should we be
about a resurgence of the disease well I
think we have to be careful I mean
you've heard us talk a lot about the
need for testing so that we don't
encounter situation where we open up and
then once again we're seeing lots of
cases when you're talking about these
cases of quote reinfection that the
Korean CDC has reported most of the
experts that we've talked to have said
that it is unlikely that these are true
re-infections it would be very unlikely
to get infected and within four eight or
twelve weeks get reinfected so those
were probably false negative tests
negative because of either the way the
test was collected or processed this is
different however from a situation when
you're looking out six months or a year
in those cases if you did not develop
full immunity you may be able to get
reinfected and this is what time is
going to tell us there may be some
individuals who don't mount a very
strong antibody response so we'll have
to see Tara Allen on Facebook ask if
you've fully recovered from the virus
should you still wear a face mask
yes Allen and everyone else is wondering
you should the CDC recommends that even
if you have recovered when you venture
out you should continue to wear those
face map
also important in terms of coming out of
your own isolation if you yourself were
sick you want to follow those guidelines
of fever free for 72 hours lessening of
your symptoms and either to negative
tests 24 hours apart or the seven days
since the first onset of symptoms
sorry I've noticed when I take walks in
a park a lot of runners and bikers are
not wearing masks our viewer Leslie asks
should they be wearing masks I noticed
this too on my run yesterday Anthony so
this is something that we all should be
aware of if you are living somewhere
that is a remote or desolate and you're
on a trail where no one else is around
it's probably fine to run or bike or
walk without a mask if however you're
somewhere like we are in New York City
where you're going to encounter other
runners bikers or walkers you do want to
go ahead and wear a mask one of the
recommendations is something called a
buff which runners know about its
moisture wicking quick drying and it's
kind of a fabric neck gaiter that you
can put over your mouth you want to try
to run or bike it off peak times and you
may want to increase the distance from
six feet to maybe 10 or 12 feet well for
from other people just because of wind
and the heart heavy breathing that you
may be doing it's possible that those
droplets could travel farther I'm Tara
I've got two questions one from Barb and
Shannon but we get this a lot barb says
should we wipe down groceries before
putting them away and Shannon from North
Carolina in the same vein says should we
wear gloves when we receive mail or
packages yeah so similar concept the the
thinking is that it's very unlikely that
this is a real high source of
transmission theoretically you could
potentially touch something that someone
else has sneezed or coughed on and then
those droplets what you would contact
them on your hands you would touch your
face eyes or nose and can get infected
that way there was a study that was
reported last month that said that the
virus is able to live on cardboard for
about 24 hours plastic and stainless
steel for two to three days that doesn't
necessarily mean that it's infectious at
that point so if you really do want to
take precaution when you bring your
grossie's in we can wipe them down
the packaging wash your hands and
disinfect the area but gloves not really
necessary alright dr. taryn the ruler I
actually my household we've been washing
our groceries and I'm very happy to hear
that maybe on this Saturday when we go
out for that shop we do not have to wash
every single one of them and ruin all
the produce that is good news in this
head of school
dr. Narula thank you very much